[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
BRIAN DORSEY: Hi and
welcome to episode 170
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
We're doing daily episodes
here at Next on the show floor.
Right now, I'm joined by Aja.
How are you doing, Aja?
AJA HAMMERLY: I am
doing great, and this
has been a fantastic event.
BRIAN DORSEY: It's been
really, really cool.
So yeah, we're doing
daily episodes,
so make sure to
tune in every day.
But why don't we just get
straight into the interviews?
AJA HAMMERLY: That
sounds like a great plan.
Let's hear what everyone
here has to say.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent,
let's do that.
GABI FERRARA: So
we're here today with?
JONATHAN CHAM: Jonathan Cham,
customer engineering manager.
GABI FERRARA: And Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And Gabi.
GABI FERRARA: We want
to know, Jonathan, what
is your experience at Next?
What do you see that you liked?
JONATHAN CHAM: So I've been
at Next three times already,
and I think we're doubling
in growth in terms
of number of attendees.
And it's just super
exciting to see
the ecosystem grow at the
scale that it is growing.
Just the number of
buildings that we're
taking over at Moscone by
itself is a clear reflection
of our growth.
And, I mean, I'm just
really excited to see
the customers, the partners,
the entire ecosystem.
The amount of
Googlers that we've
been hiring, as well, just
to support the tremendous
needs from our customers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, it's been super busy.
And there's obviously--
like you said,
we're taking over more space.
There's more showcases here.
They're building it
up higher and taller
than they've ever been.
You said earlier,
we're only-- what?
Two hours into
the next 2019 now.
Is there anything
that's caught your eye?
Anything you're
super excited about?
JONATHAN CHAM: I mean,
right now, we just
talked about Anthos.
That's something
that all my customers
have been talking
about, multi-cloud,
hybrid cloud, flexibility,
agility, scalability,
reliability, security,
performance, all of that.
The announcement
around Anthos, I think,
is going to be a
really big talking
point across all our
customers, especially
in the enterprise space, right?
That's just something that
they continue to speak about,
is look, I love
Google, but I also
have been using
other clouds as well.
How can you help me
leverage the investments
I've already made
into something that I
can use across multiple
cloud providers?
So I think it's going
to be huge for us.
And we've had, what, 20 years
of open source investment?
It's something that we do.
It's in our DNA.
So I really think
that it's going
to be a really big thing
across all our customers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think it's nice, too, because
a lot of people have been--
like you said, people have
been really interested in this,
and they've been
learning about it.
And Google's been
talking about it,
and they have a lot of
server-less offerings.
But it's kind of great to see
the floodgates open up today
and just say, here
all these cool things.
They're finally here, they're
ready for people to use.
You can get started with them.
A lot of them are in beta.
We were just talking
to the Cloud Run folks.
I think there's a
lot there that people
can get their hands on right
now and start working with,
and then hopefully kind of
see, how do I bring my business
and solve more
problems with this?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
It's super exciting.
I mean, just walking
down the stairs,
the amount of time it
takes to go down the stairs
is also a clear reflection
of how busy it is.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's Just like, all
right, are we going to walk,
are we going to run?
It's packed here right now.
So it's exciting.
GABI FERRARA: What do you
think about the keynote?
Did you watch it?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
I mean, TK-- look, he's a
veteran in the industry.
So watching him
speak with clarity
and helping us
internally as well as
externally understand the
priorities of Google Cloud--
I mean, he's a
new leader for us.
And so to see him put
everything together
with the help from Diane
Green is very refreshing.
And I think his focus on
not only the enterprise
but all our customers, I
think, is going to really show
in our product showcase.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think there's going to be
a lot of cool stuff coming up
of the next couple days.
And then as TK comes in and
starts to kind of redefine
what we're going
for, I think we're
going to see some really,
really cool stuff from Google
this year.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
It's going to be fun.
GABI FERRARA: I am
excited for announcements,
but I can't open my mouth now.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Can you tell us
what announcements there are?
GABI FERRARA: I don't know
if they were announced.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You were
looking at me like you've got
something you wanted
to share but you can't.
JONATHAN CHAM: There's so much.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's messed up.
JONATHAN CHAM: And they're
just waiting and just waiting
for this stuff, for
the floodgates to open.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
I'm just [INAUDIBLE] here
ready to tweet about it.
JONATHAN CHAM: Don't play poker.
That's all I've got to say.
You're just a
terrible poker player.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It's exciting, right?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
It's really exciting.
I mean, I'd love to
hang out with you more,
because then I could tell,
oh, something new's coming up.
Just watch out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I think
everyone listening, hopefully,
will get to see all these
things come out in social media.
Obviously, if
you're here, you're
probably having a great time.
If you're not here,
then come here next year
and kind of get all the
excitement for yourself.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
And if you're not here,
go bug your account team
for some passes.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
Oh, also, there is
Cloud Next on Air.
JONATHAN CHAM: Oh, yeah.
That was our thing, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: They're
still doing it this year.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, of course.
Yeah, Stephanie.
Stephanie Wong actually was on
right before I walked in here.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So we've
got the live streams,
we've got all the recorded
content, some of the sessions
are going to be live, and
then a lot of this content
is going to get out
there on YouTube.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
Fun times.
GABI FERRARA: OK,
thank you so much.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
Thank you.
Bye.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
Thanks so much, Jonathan.
GABI FERRARA: So we are
here today with Ori.
And, Ori, can you
present yourself to us?
ORI KASHI: Absolutely.
So I'm Ori Kashi.
I'm a product manager
on the Cloud SQL
team focused on SQL Server.
GABI FERRARA: Ooh, so that
was just announced, right?
ORI KASHI: Yeah.
We just announced it this
morning in the keynote.
And you probably saw our demo.
It was showing how you onboard
onto Managed SQL Server
from legacy databases.
GABI FERRARA: So is this a
private alpha or public alpha--
it's going to be?
ORI KASHI: So right now
it's just a private alpha.
Second half of this year, we're
going to go with a public beta.
But for right now, we're looking
for folks that are interested.
We already have a
set of customers,
but there's an
interest sheet that you
can sign up for on our website.
GABI FERRARA: Oh, cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So, I mean, this
is something people have
been asking for some time.
ORI KASHI: Oh, yeah.
I mean, SQL Server has
historically always
been in the top three databases
that our enterprise customers
are using.
And it's been cited time
and time again as something
that folks looking
to take advantage
of GCP's other services
want to make sure
that they don't have to
abandon their legacy SQL server
footprint behind.
And so what this does is
give us an opportunity
to kind of bring it along.
Don't have to
transform right away.
I mean, they could
just bring in it as is,
and it will run very well
in our managed service.
And then they can take their
time kind of re-architecting
and recreating their solutions.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
So now it's on a blocker
to move to the cloud.
ORI KASHI: Exactly.
GABI FERRARA: And
they just worry
about the data, not
everything else?
ORI KASHI: Correct, correct.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
right now, Cloud SQL
still supports MySQL and
Postgres as well, right?
ORI KASHI: Correct.
So this is a great indication
of how we're expanding
the portfolio for Cloud SQL.
So you can continue to expect
us devoting more energy
into the platform, and
making sure we're compatible,
and hosting more databases.
GABI FERRARA: I'm
excited about that.
ORI KASHI: Yeah.
It has been a very
exciting ride.
And I know the teams worked
really hard to get us here.
And where we're super
happy to have customers
start using our product.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
Any other cool Cloud
SQL-related announcements
that you want to talk about?
ORI KASHI: I think the SQL
Server, taking advantage
of the platform that
Cloud SQL is already on,
is one of the things that
many folks take for granted.
So it would be good
to call out that all
the same great features in
terms of regional availability,
and automatic backups, and
everything else people have
come to expect from
Cloud SQL is also going
to be available for SQL Server.
And so that's super
exciting, that it's not
just the great
SQL Server product
that folks have
been used to using,
but also now enhanced
with all the goodness that
comes with Cloud SQL and GCP.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Anything else at Next
you're super excited to see?
ORI KASHI: Yeah.
I mean, there's not enough time
in the day to see everything.
I'm really excited.
And with part of
the keynote demo
this morning was the rest
of our new advancements
in the Windows ecosystem on GCP.
And so you probably
saw me demoing--
Managed AD is also
coming out, and a bunch
of other services, as well.
And so I think we have a really
good, complete story for,
if you are in window
shop today, if you have
certain solutions that
require that ecosystem,
we can support that.
Then that shouldn't be a
blocker for you in adopting GCP.
GABI FERRARA: Cool.
Thank you, Ori.
Is there anything
else that you want
to talk to us about
Cloud SQL Server?
ORI KASHI: No, I think
that's most of it.
That's plenty.
There's a lot.
But I definitely
encourage folks that
are interested-- we'll be
releasing a lot of information
now.
There's a sign-up
sheet you know if you
do want to participate
in our alpha.
And definitely look forward to
having everyone try it out when
it goes beta later this year.
GABI FERRARA: OK, thank you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks so much.
ORI KASHI: Thank you so much.
AJA HAMMERLY: Hi!
We're in the podcast house
here at GCP Next today.
It is Tuesday in the afternoon,
so some of the cool talks
have already happened, like
Brian's talk earlier today.
And you were nice enough
to come hang out with us.
So can you tell us who you are?
MATT BROWN: Yeah, absolutely.
My name is Matt Brown.
I'm a solutions
architect at Skuid--
and that's spelled S-K-U-I-D.
We're a low-code development
platform and tool for all
kinds of data and platforms.
And yeah.
Happy to be here from
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
NATE KORHONEN: I
know, Chatta-where-a?
MATT BROWN: We love it.
It's good.
NATE KORHONEN:
I'm Nate Korhonen,
and I basically get to
serve Matt every day.
Just kind of stepping into a--
MATT BROWN: He's my butler.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: Nice gig.
NATE KORHONEN:
--new role in kind
of an enablement org for Skuid.
So we've been working with kind
of professional services-type
stuff for the company for
the last couple of years.
And just like what you're
doing, developer relations,
we got to this point where
it's like, we really need
people to just focus on that.
And so we kind of spun up here
in the last couple months.
And Google Next happens to
be the first event that we're
coming in just the
capacity of, we
want to see how it's done right.
And we're like, OK, who
could possibly do it right?
BRIAN DORSEY: So is
this a scouting mission?
Is this why you're here?
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
MATT BROWN: Oh, yeah.
NATE KORHONEN: And
y'all nailed it.
We literally-- we got
delayed yesterday.
We had to sit in Chattanooga
airport for a while.
Sorry, American Airlines.
We had to spend the night
in Dallas Fort Worth.
And so we finally
got here today.
And so, I don't know,
we've been on the floor
for literally five minutes--
MATT BROWN: Yeah, this is our
first thing that we're doing.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
And, boom, here is the podcast.
BRIAN DORSEY: You just
walk right into the house
on the podcast.
MATT BROWN: It
looks so inviting.
It's like the cottage
in Hansel and Gretel.
You guys are going
to eat us, right?
BRIAN DORSEY: Not in the plans.
AJA HAMMERLY: No, I do not
think that is on the plan,
because there's plenty
of snacks elsewhere.
NATE KORHONEN: Okay, good.
Good.
MATT BROWN: Whew.
AJA HAMMERLY: So what's
one thing each of you
is looking forward to
seeing while you're here
at the conference?
NATE KORHONEN: Firebase.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome choice.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
MATT BROWN: I want to see
more about SQL databases
on Google Cloud.
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, yeah.
We announced a beta of, was it--
BRIAN DORSEY: Postgres 11.
AJA HAMMERLY:
Managed Postgres 11
on Cloud SQL, who's
beta as of this morning.
NATE KORHONEN: Ooh.
AJA HAMMERLY: Which is super
exciting for all of our friends
who like to have up-to-date
frameworks and tools so
that they don't have
security issues.
MATT BROWN: We've got a lot
of Postgres junkies at Skuid.
AJA HAMMERLY: That's cool.
MATT BROWN: So, yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY:
What's one thing you
want to copy from this
event that was so awesome?
NATE KORHONEN: Literally
this place right here.
So they've got this amazing
kind of glass house,
little, mini, cute area.
It's contained enough.
MATT BROWN: I'm holding
[INAUDIBLE] in my hand
right now.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
And just a really cool setup.
I took a picture
and they just waved.
And it was so warm.
It was so inviting.
BRIAN DORSEY: Aww.
NATE KORHONEN: And
they said, come.
Come in here, talk to us.
And that's amazing.
So like that.
I want to replicate that.
MATT BROWN: I loved
looking in the app
and seeing how you can
set up to three meetings
with an expert for 30 minutes.
NATE KORHONEN:
That's pretty killer.
MATT BROWN: And on any topic.
That's just really cool.
I like that a lot.
BRIAN DORSEY: Connecting
with people, right?
MATT BROWN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Because ultimately,
it comes down
to having a real conversation
about a real problem
that you're trying to solve.
And we can talk about
it at a high level,
but ultimately, it
comes down to that.
And that's true of
this kind of stuff,
too, on the podcast level.
Actual dialogue is where stuff
kind of rises to the top.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yep.
Technology is all about people,
despite what everyone thinks.
NATE KORHONEN: So can we
ask a little bit about that
for y'all?
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, sure.
NATE KORHONEN: As far
as developer relations.
How did that become a thing?
How long has that been a thing?
Or how long have you been
at that-- in that role,
or part of this thing?
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm going
to go first because you've
been at Google longer.
I've been doing dev role at
Google for about four years.
Dev role has been
around at Google
a fair amount longer than that.
I think we're fast
approaching the 10-year mark--
something like that-- of the
developer advocate title.
NATE KORHONEN: Oh, man.
AJA HAMMERLY: It's close.
It's been a while.
NATE KORHONEN: Congratulations.
AJA HAMMERLY: And we pull
people from all over.
We like having people with
lots of different backgrounds.
And the big thing is, you have
to be excited about technology,
and you have to be excited
about talking with people.
Do not have to be an extrovert.
There's a super secret,
that a lot of our dev
role folks do dev role because
they have a list of topics
they can talk about
and they don't
have to make small talk ever.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: So true.
MATT BROWN: That's great.
BRIAN DORSEY: Or, like, on and
then off at the end of the day.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
Well, it's still good stuff.
If you love what you
talk about, that works.
MATT BROWN: Yeah.
NATE KORHONEN: So is there
something particularly
you like, Aja, talking about?
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh,
I'm a generalist.
You know Brian and I,
and we are the two--
we'll not go with
fearless leaders,
but leaders of some kind--
of our application
development outreach group.
NATE KORHONEN: There you go.
AJA HAMMERLY: And we
kind of do all the stuff.
I am particularly
passionate about languages,
programming languages.
I like too many of them.
And I tried to get
everyone in the dev zone
this morning to tell me
their favorite language,
and they all just
kind of stared at me.
So it was probably a
little early for my level
of enthusiasm.
But it's OK.
I threw some dinosaur
facts at them
and they still stared at me.
NATE KORHONEN: OK, top three.
BRIAN DORSEY: I can
do the dinosaur facts.
NATE KORHONEN: I've
got to know this.
BRIAN DORSEY: I can
do the dinosaur facts.
NATE KORHONEN: Wait, go for it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Top
three dinosaurs?
NATE KORHONEN: Well, no.
I wanted the languages.
BRIAN DORSEY: Or top three
programming languages?
NATE KORHONEN: But you go ahead.
AJA HAMMERLY: Hey, Brian.
Hey, Brian.
Why don't you talk about the
stuff that makes you excited?
Because you gave a talk
this morning already.
BRIAN DORSEY: I did.
But I'm actually only going
to talk about part of it.
So I had to give a
talk on how to choose
between the different
compute stuff.
NATE KORHONEN: Ooh.
BRIAN DORSEY: And I just get
really excited about VMs.
And they're kind of
considered boring tech,
but they're this amazing
boring tech when they're
a slice of a data center.
You can have all this cool,
ephemeral stuff you can do,
it adapts really
quickly, and it's
the next step for almost
every real system that
already exists.
If you're building
something new,
there's a whole bunch
of stuff to look at,
but if you've got
a thing already,
probably your biggest value
step is getting into a VM.
NATE KORHONEN:
Forgive my ignorance.
Is that the GCE?
Is that what we're
talking about?
BRIAN DORSEY: That
is Compute Engine.
NATE KORHONEN: Wow.
BRIAN DORSEY: Google
Compute Engine.
Exactly.
MATT BROWN: Nice, Nate.
BRIAN DORSEY: [INAUDIBLE]
acronym, check.
AJA HAMMERLY: Hey, Brian.
Did I see TK saying something
about really big VMs
this morning?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, we've got--
we announced some
really big VMs.
AJA HAMMERLY: How big
a VM can we get now?
BRIAN DORSEY: So,
for comparison,
you can get 400-some VCPUs
and almost 12 terabytes of RAM
soon.
And for context, I went
an looked up the biggest
hard drive you could get
on the internet and buy,
and that's 14 terabytes.
So pretty soon
you're going to be
able to turn on a VM
with about as much RAM
as the biggest hard
drive you can buy.
MATT BROWN: Pocket universe.
NATE KORHONEN: Is there--
can we talk costs at all?
Rough ballpark, is there
any idea what that--
BRIAN DORSEY: It adds up
when you get that big.
Because we basically
do the prices
by gigabyte of memory over
time and by CPU, so it adds up.
But you can also
get those machines
for a really short
amount of time.
NATE KORHONEN: So it's flexible.
BRIAN DORSEY: You don't have
to buy it and keep it forever.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
We still bill to the
10 minute, right?
First 10 minutes and
then every minute after?
Something like that?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So I think it's even
maybe to the second.
But at the first 10-minute
threshold for VMs.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
You have to pay for 10
minutes, I know that.
So make many, many small jobs.
NATE KORHONEN: Cool.
And don't make them
talk to each other
in infinite loops that
just rack up the bill.
AJA HAMMERLY: Well, infinite
loops are just generally bad.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
AJA HAMMERLY: So
are there any talks
that you know you're going to
be going to while you're here?
Have you looked
at the app at all
to figure out what
talks you want to be at?
MATT BROWN: I'll be honest--
AJA HAMMERLY: [GASP]
You have a program.
MATT BROWN: I do.
BRIAN DORSEY: Like,
a physical paper one.
AJA HAMMERLY: That's fancy.
It's, like, made out of trees.
MATT BROWN: Is that OK?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah,
no, that's cool.
I haven't seen one of those.
MATT BROWN: So I'm
going to keep it.
I'm not just going to--
AJA HAMMERLY: I haven't
seen one of those.
MATT BROWN: --throw it out.
Yeah.
NATE KORHONEN: I love it.
She's describing, like,
a relic of a lost age.
AJA HAMMERLY: Well, I was
looking for one earlier
and couldn't find one.
MATT BROWN: So I'll be honest.
There's a little bit of
fish out of water for me,
because I don't come from
a development background.
And I got into
application development
through our product, which is--
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh,
that's awesome.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
what is your background?
AJA HAMMERLY: Lot
of folks on our team
don't come from a development
background, either.
MATT BROWN: Cool, cool.
All right.
Well, then, great.
So I'm a fish out of
water with other fish
that are out of water.
Or maybe it's just a new pond?
I don't know.
AJA HAMMERLY: I think--
MATT BROWN: We don't need
to continue the metaphor.
AJA HAMMERLY: I think we made
you a flying fish and you're
all in outer space.
MATT BROWN: I like it.
That's great.
NATE KORHONEN: Oh, wow.
MATT BROWN: Yeah, no.
NATE KORHONEN: Upgrade.
MATT BROWN: So yeah,
our product basically
is built around
setting up a data
source to just about anything
you might want to connect to--
NATE KORHONEN:
Including Google stuff.
MATT BROWN: Yeah.
Whether it's kind of
more managed CRM things,
like Salesforce, or
Microsoft Dynamics,
or a homegrown Postgres database
that you set up, or Rest,
or connecting to Google
Maps, and different APIs,
and stuff like that.
So it helped me go from being
on kind of the businessesy sales
end of things to doing a lot
of creative and problem-solving
stuff using technology.
So it was really exciting.
I absolutely love the product.
And so coming here, I've been
interested in things like--
I actually missed, because
we got turned around,
Country Boys in the Big City.
There was a rapid
prototyping in public sector.
We've got a number of
public sector customers.
And so wanted to see, how do
you put something in front
of someone that looks useful--
like what they want to
see-- really, really
quickly, and then start
iterating and building on it?
That's what's really
exciting to me.
NATE KORHONEN: We've got
to find an encore of that.
MATT BROWN: Yeah, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] a couple
of different--
AJA HAMMERLY: And
everything was recorded.
And if we manage to do
what we did last year--
NATE KORHONEN: Oh, man.
Yes.
AJA HAMMERLY:
--everything should
be on YouTube within about
48 hours, if not faster.
MATT BROWN: OK.
Awesome.
AJA HAMMERLY: I don't
know how many people they
have working in the video
room, but they have a lot
NATE KORHONEN: No kidding.
AJA HAMMERLY: Because
we're turning around 20
and 30 sessions every hour?
MATT BROWN: Wow.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
MATT BROWN: That's awesome.
AJA HAMMERLY: This
event is bigger
than some people's hometowns,
which I found out yesterday.
MATT BROWN: Yes, absolutely.
NATE KORHONEN: So here's
another plug, speaking of that.
We have our own doc
site, and we have our own
but, you get stuck,
first thing you do?
Well, I Google it.
Y'all still own, the first
question I'm going to ask,
I'm going to Google it.
And the second thing
I'm going to do
is YouTube it, so you're
number one and number two,
just for, how do
I do that thing?
BRIAN DORSEY: I both
super appreciate that,
and I have a little bit of
potty humor going on in my head
that--
MATT BROWN: That's OK.
There's an--
NATE KORHONEN: Highly
utilitarian in all cases.
MATT BROWN: There's
an acceptable amount
on the podcast threshold.
NATE KORHONEN: Well played, sir.
AJA HAMMERLY: I
was going to say,
we should probably
wrap up soon--
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, I
think we probably should.
AJA HAMMERLY: --so
that we can let you
guys get back to the event.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah.
MATT BROWN: Yeah,
there's so much to see.
Like, we literally
stopped at JetBrains
because we've got
some folks back
at Skuid that love
Colin and IntelliJ.
That's it.
And then we were here.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
I highly recommend that,
since we're hanging out here
in the podcast
booth, just behind
us is the industry section.
And they've got some of the
coolest demos, in my opinion.
MATT BROWN: OK, cool.
We'll go check it out.
AJA HAMMERLY: So we have our
retail friends and our gaming
friends over there.
MATT BROWN: Are there
robots anywhere?
AJA HAMMERLY: I know
there is a robot.
I saw it yesterday.
I think it was
over in the machine
learning section that way.
MATT BROWN: All right, cool.
My son is four, and
he loves robots.
So if I could get a
picture of a robot--
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm 36,
and I love robots too.
MATT BROWN: Oh, yeah.
Oh, me too.
Absolutely.
It's not an age thing.
AJA HAMMERLY: No, no.
Robots are just cool.
MATT BROWN: Oh, no.
AJA HAMMERLY: Everyone
loves robots and gaming.
MATT BROWN: Absolutely.
AJA HAMMERLY: This is
pretty much what I learned.
MATT BROWN: Awesome.
Have an awesome event.
Cool.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, thank
you so much for coming
to chat with us.
NATE KORHONEN: Yeah, thank you.
MATT BROWN: Thank you guys.
This is great.
NATE KORHONEN: Thank you.
BRYAN KOKISH: Well,
I'm having a hard time.
So, wait, these go on my ears?
Oh, I gotcha.
I gotcha.
JOSE PAGAN: I hope you
guys realize that this
may be the session of the week.
I'm feeling good
about this right now.
BRIAN DORSEY: You set a
pretty high bar there.
Can you introduce
yourself so we know
who just said
they're going to have
the most impressive, amazing--
JOSE PAGAN: I think that's why.
I'm feeling-- it's organic.
I'm starting to feel
really good about this.
Until I looked at
him having problems
putting his headphones on.
No, this is Jose Pagan.
I'm a deployment lead from Onix.
And I'm going to go ahead
and go on the record
and say that I
think this might be
the best session of the week.
Yeah, I think so.
And it hasn't started yet.
BRIAN DORSEY: Right on.
Let's make it happen.
Who else do we have?
BRYAN KOKISH: I am Bryan Kokish.
I'm the marketing
director at Onix.
AJA HAMMERLY: It's Aja again.
BRIAN DORSEY: And Brian.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, and Brian.
So what brings you all to Next?
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah, we
are a Google Partner, one
of the first Google Partners.
So, obviously, we're
here for that reason.
We're Onix from Lakewood Ohio.
Started in the '90s in
the networking business
and kind of evolved
the technology,
and now we are a premier Google
Partner and a multiple Partner
of the Year winner.
JOSE PAGAN: Also one of the
first partners of Google,
if I'm not mistaken.
BRYAN KOKISH: A first or second.
Yeah--
JOSE PAGAN: First
or second partner.
BRYAN KOKISH: It's one of
those things that's argued
back and forth, you know?
BRIAN DORSEY: Do we have a
database for that or something?
I think we should know.
JOSE PAGAN: I think that
everybody here has a database.
You couldn't get in
until you had a database.
BRIAN DORSEY: It's
just part of the entry?
JOSE PAGAN: Part of the entry?
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah.
Everyone here has a
database, but none of them
speak to each other.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSE PAGAN: No doubt.
That's why I'm
employed, actually,
so we can help connect
all the databases together
to speak to each other
in different languages.
BRIAN DORSEY: So you mentioned
you do stand-up comedy.
JOSE PAGAN: 14 years.
BRIAN DORSEY: 14 years.
AJA HAMMERLY: Wow.
JOSE PAGAN: Yeah, I know.
It's a lot of booths.
BRYAN KOKISH: Now,
when you say "booze,"
is that spelled B-O-O-Z-E?
JOSE PAGAN: Booths.
BRYAN KOKISH: Oh, oh.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, wow.
I misheard that too.
JOSE PAGAN: Everything
is debatable on podcasts.
Bryan also has some
stand-up comedy chops.
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah, I did
stand-up for about 10 years.
And then I met a woman and
my career pretty much ended.
I got married and had kids
and lived the rest of my days
in bitterness.
BRIAN DORSEY: It
seems like there
would be some potential content
there, things to talk about
through those life experiences.
JOSE PAGAN: Oh, there's content.
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah,
there's definitely content,
but you get to the point
in life where it's just not
really funny anymore,
when you're the joke
and you're living it.
JOSE PAGAN: Before,
we don't know
what the content looks like.
I think we have to check the
parental guidance ratings
on this podcast to make sure.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
I'm thinking,
because last year, I
don't have this
level of credentials
on the stand-up comedy.
BRYAN KOKISH: And
I'm sure there's
a lot of young kids
at home listening.
JOSE PAGAN: "I don't
have those credentials."
Could you laboring on
that a little bit for me?
What you mean by credentials?
I'm curious.
BRIAN DORSEY: I mean
years of experience.
JOSE PAGAN: Years of
experience or years of torment?
Perspective is everything.
AJA HAMMERLY: Are
they different?
JOSE PAGAN: They could be.
I mean, they could be.
BRIAN DORSEY: Are we talking
about tech or company now?
AJA HAMMERLY: Why not both?
JOSE PAGAN: No doubt.
That's the best part about it.
I think that we bridge
the gap for both.
That's one of our specialties.
The culture is something
special at Onix as well.
It's like one big happy family.
There's this overlying synergy
that we work hard, play hard.
I mean, I hang out with these
people outside of work a ton.
So it's fun to come
to an event like this.
I'm not going to lie.
When I saw the podcast,
my eyes lit up.
Because I think this
is a great idea.
In the middle of it all.
I mean, you guys have
got a great location.
You know, right here.
AJA HAMMERLY: And we've got
this super stylish house.
JOSE PAGAN: It's very stylish.
It is.
BRYAN KOKISH: It is very nice.
JOSE PAGAN: I think
it's very green.
BRYAN KOKISH: I was going
to say, a greenhouse,
or it looks like
an old photo mat.
JOSE PAGAN: Oh my gosh,
you're dating yourself.
And I hate the fact that
I know what you mean.
With the drive and photo mats?
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah, exactly.
JOSE PAGAN: Yeah.
BRYAN KOKISH:
Weird people there.
JOSE PAGAN: That was between the
digital camera and the Polaroid
picture years.
BRYAN KOKISH: Exactly, yeah.
JOSE PAGAN: You know those
weird rolls that fit right in,
and then you had to get
them developed and it
took like five years?
And then after you
got them developed,
you were moving from like
dorm room to dorm room,
you still found 30 rolls
that were undeveloped?
It was just, like,
never developing.
We're going to see how
old they are in a minute,
because they're looking
at us kind of puzzling.
AJA HAMMERLY: No, I'm
not looking at you.
I'm not looking at you funny.
I'm just remembering
all those years
I spent in a darkroom
spooling films
so that I could develop it.
So, yeah.
That was lots of fun.
BRYAN KOKISH: And you're dating
yourself there at that point.
Because about time that you
finished learning all that,
that's when the digital
age started to happen.
JOSE PAGAN: Years and years
of developing the film.
So let me ask you, how long did
you work at the photo houses?
AJA HAMMERLY: I didn't.
I did it for fun.
Because I had bad hobbies.
BRYAN KOKISH: I was
going to say, wow.
AJA HAMMERLY: [INAUDIBLE].
I liked playing chemistry set.
It was fun.
So what are you guys excited
about at the conference?
Is there any session
you're looking forward
to, or any product
announcements, or parties, any
of the above?
JOSE PAGAN: No,
honestly, I'm going
to be the lame guy in here.
I mean, I'm not really--
I've been to a couple of
parties already with Google,
and the reception last
night to kick things
off was pretty cool.
I mean, the food was fantastic.
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah,
that was great.
JOSE PAGAN: It was awesome.
I just-- I'm more around the
technology side of things,
and seeing what everybody
brings to the table.
My division is
enterprise search,
so I'm probably going
to play favorites here.
I've been to a couple of
great Cloud Search sessions.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
JOSE PAGAN: And I've also been
in an awesome Cloud Platform
session, too.
So it's really cool stuff.
This is my first time at Next,
so I'm kind of a Next rookie.
BRIAN DORSEY: Cool.
Have you see any
interesting stories
of what people are
doing with Search?
Or you said
enterprise and search.
And so I was curious.
[INAUDIBLE]
AJA HAMMERLY: What
does that look like?
Are there any awesome stories
that you're allowed to share?
JOSE PAGAN: In a nutshell, think
of Google for your internal
use case.
So you own a company and you
have a huge amount of data.
You have no way to find it.
One of our popular use cases--
which I'll just talk about
because that was in
the last session--
was Philips Healthcare, where
their techs had a ton of data,
but they didn't know
how to bring it together
in order to do repairs
on healthcare equipment.
CTE machines, and CAT
scans, and all those types
of pieces of
equipment and stuff.
So it allowed them to put it
all in one central location
and then bring it
into a use case
so that people doing
service on those machines--
I mean, the overlying
downtime of those machines
was improved almost by 30%.
AJA HAMMERLY: Wow.
JOSE PAGAN: Yeah.
So it's powerful stuff.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
this is like being
able to search for
the error message,
but for this really particular--
JOSE PAGAN: Correct.
So that error message
that they would find--
a technician would find--
it would be in this huge
handbook of thousands of pages.
And they'd have to take that,
oh, this is error message code
J7359.
I did add a "niner" in there.
And then they would
go and look for it--
BRIAN DORSEY: It's
the headphones, right?
JOSE PAGAN: --and take forever.
I know, the headphones
were appropriate.
I feel like some sort
of pilot right now.
I'm going into my "niner" phase.
But, yeah.
And it would take them a
long time to make a fix
and itemize what the problem was
from an analytical standpoint
in order to target that fix.
Immediately, that
improves productivity,
decreases downtime, helps them
make that fix a lot quicker.
So it's pretty cool
stuff when there's
a good use case [INAUDIBLE].
BRYAN KOKISH: And the thing
about that, too, is it really
transcends industry.
So one of the things that
you have to think about
is, the baby boomers are
retiring en masse right now.
And so what you have
going on, what we
call institutional memory loss.
So in the instance that you
were talking about with Philips
Healthcare, I actually used
to work for Philips Medical
Systems, and worked
in radiology.
So I know it all too well.
So what happens-- and it
happens in every line of work--
you have people that retire, get
fired, leave, whatever it is.
And what they do is,
they take with them
all that knowledge that they
built up over the years that's
institutional knowledge.
And what happens is,
there's a giant vacuum.
There's a gap.
So something like
Enterprise Search
helps address that by
getting everything,
all that information, all
that data, on the cloud
so people can readily find it.
Otherwise, you have situations--
and I've been in this situation
before-- where we've had
somebody leave a job,
it's shut down part of what
we were actually doing.
Because nobody knew what
to do at that point.
JOSE PAGAN: Yeah, the
knowledge management piece
is huge in regards to that.
And then that's just one
of the many products.
I mean, we're all-- we're
in Onspend shirts today.
Onspend's another
one of our products.
It adds a cloud
billing software.
We're very big into GCP.
We're very big into G Suite.
G Suite's another one
of our [INAUDIBLE]..
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
Did you have any favorite
announcements from the event
so far?
JOSE PAGAN: Favorite
announcements.
BRYAN KOKISH: So,
so far, I think
I'm looking forward to the--
seeing what goes on at
the awards today, I think,
will be kind of cool.
That's always exciting for
a lot of different folks.
And also, just walking
around and seeing
all the different booths
and all the technologies,
and seeing that cloud
icon right there.
And see how many
times it's actually
been used throughout the hall.
Because I've actually seen
that about six or seven times,
and other logos.
And those poor folks that have
that cloud icon, or that logo,
and realize that, yeah,
we were the only ones that
thought maybe we'd come up
with a logo with a cloud on it.
No one else would
come up with that.
JOSE PAGAN: And you're
going on a whole other level
of copyright infringement that
we need to pull Onix legal in,
I think.
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah.
JOSE PAGAN: [INAUDIBLE]
this conversation.
I think the other
thing-- to piggyback
on what you're saying,
though, all joking aside,
is the bridging of
different backgrounds
and different organizations,
different demographics, people
all over the world
that come across.
And you finally get to see
them face-to-face that use
your products, and talk
about how much of a benefit
it is in their organization.
That's kind of special to me.
BRYAN KOKISH: Or even
people you work with.
I mean, there's people
I've never met before,
I know them via
email, and I just
know their little
headshot via email.
I'm like, I know you.
And then, all of
a sudden, you're
actually getting to
meet them, and realizing
they're not as nice as
you thought they were--
JOSE PAGAN: Oh, my god.
BRYAN KOKISH: --digitally
speaking, and that you--
JOSE PAGAN: You just turned
around from legal to HR.
I mean, you're just
hitting everything that's--
BRYAN KOKISH: Oh, I'm going to.
Hey, we're going to be
compelling and intriguing.
Why not go full
Monty on that one?
JOSE PAGAN: I love how you're
pushing the envelope right now.
I'm telling you.
You're preaching my--
you're speaking my language.
BRYAN KOKISH: Even Jose.
I mean, I think we met the
first day-- my first day there,
and Jose came in.
We're talking, and I find out
that he's a stand-up comic.
I mean, how many stand-up
comics work at that place?
JOSE PAGAN: Two.
We're looking at them.
BRYAN KOKISH: Just us two?
I thought a couple of others--
JOSE PAGAN: There are a few
others that have never been
on stage, but claim--
our CEO and owner--
and I won't say this,
because he's not on--
he's actually a
really funny guy.
BRYAN KOKISH: He is very funny.
JOSE PAGAN: I won't
tell him to his face.
I will never-- he'll never
tell me to my face, but.
BRIAN DORSEY: I mean, this
may end up [INAUDIBLE] where.
It's going to be
on the internet.
JOSE PAGAN: I mean, that's fine.
I doubt he'll listen.
If he does, then he gets
to hear my little secret.
But I don't even know if the
guy checks his email yet.
I haven't-- [INAUDIBLE].
BRYAN KOKISH: He does.
Trust me on that.
He does.
JOSE PAGAN: No, we have such
a great relationship at work.
And everybody has so much fun.
But the thing about Onix,
when we all come together,
is there's one collective whole.
And that's the client--
client satisfaction
is huge to us.
We just found a way to perfect
having fun while doing it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
Well, here's to more
gatherings, and meeting people,
and connecting all the--
and re-building stuff.
JOSE PAGAN: Absolutely.
Thanks for the invite.
If you guys ever stop by the
Cleveland office, stop on over.
I mean, we have little--
our basin's--
AJA HAMMERLY: Will do.
JOSE PAGAN: --pretty Google-y.
We have a lot of
fun games and stuff.
So I know a lot of people don't
like to come to Cleveland.
That's the running
joke over there.
They're like, where
are you located?
I'm like, oh,
we're in Cleveland.
They're like, oh-ho, what's
in Cleveland, the Browns?
It's, like, the hottest team
to talk about right now.
BRYAN KOKISH: And
they're kidding.
Yeah.
JOSE PAGAN: Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
The one guy last night
at the Partner reception
kind of laughed
in my face when I
said that we're three to five
years away from a Super Bowl.
And he asked me how many
drinks I had, to be honest.
BRYAN KOKISH: Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
What did you say, three to five?
JOSE PAGAN: Three to five
years away from a Super Bowl.
I'm going to stand by that.
BRYAN KOKISH: How
about one to two?
JOSE PAGAN: Going to
radio sports talk.
BRYAN KOKISH: One
other last plug.
Actually, a lot
of companies talk
about corporate
social responsibility.
Tim Needles is our CEO
and really lives it.
I almost jumped an
announcement that we have,
something-- but we do a
lot with the homeless.
And in terms of--
JOSE PAGAN: Oh, I remember.
BRYAN KOKISH: Yeah.
JOSE PAGAN: Yeah,
we have a nonprofit
that him and his
wife created called
Onix Outreach that
helps fight hunger
and homelessness in Cleveland.
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, awesome.
JOSE PAGAN: Oh, it's fantastic.
Yeah, check out the website.
And for them to
give back like that
is a direct relation on
who they are as people.
I mean, we are fascinating
people to work with.
BRYAN KOKISH: And the thing
is, the whole company's
involved in that.
It's actually
written into our HR.
What do we get, a day?
JOSE PAGAN: We get one
furlough day a year
to do [INAUDIBLE]
nonprofit work.
BRYAN KOKISH: To
do volunteer work.
AJA HAMMERLY: That's awesome.
JOSE PAGAN: And then throughout
the rest of the year,
everybody helps out with--
I mean, every year
around Christmas time,
we do a clothing and food drive.
I mean, we work with
some of the most
considerate and platinum-hearted
individuals across the planet.
And I'm pretty
sure, saying that.
There's not even a joke there.
That's just fact.
BRYAN KOKISH: I think that's
why we're all there, too.
JOSE PAGAN: Absolutely.
BRYAN KOKISH: I mean,
we're really proud of that.
JOSE PAGAN: Yeah, it
definitely pushes you forward
as an employee.
It's something that's
inspiring, and it just
makes you a better person.
You want to make it better.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
Well, thanks for being here.
BRYAN KOKISH: Absolutely.
Thanks for the invite.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thanks
for [INAUDIBLE]..
BRYAN KOKISH: This
is a lot of fun.
We appreciate it.
JOSE PAGAN: We appreciate it.
BRYAN KOKISH: Nice
meeting you guys.
BRYAN KOKISH: Thank you so much.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thank you to
everyone for joining us today
with these awesome episodes
live from the Google Next show
floor.
Please tune in tomorrow
for another episode
with more interviews from more
attendees at this conference.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
See you then.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]